bonjour monsieur le président madame et
messieurs les ministres bonjour à tous
chers collègues nous avons l'honneur
d'accueillir aujourd'hui les membres du
gouvernement et du parlement birman en
exil
il s'agit du professeur the way sceaux
et ministre de la santé de l'éducation
du gouvernement d'unité nationale
le docteur sarr ministre de la
coopération internationale
madame jean marc wang ministre des
affaires étrangères pour évoquer la
situation en birmanie
par ailleurs nous fait aussi l'honneur
de participer à cette audition
monsieur wang qing nyunt qui est préside
le comité permanent de l'assemblée de
l'union
nous avons entendu faire inviter nous
avons entendu le 10 février dernier
notre ambassadeur de france en birmanie
monsieur christian le sheikh vie qui a
évoqué devant nous le coup d'état
militaire perpétré par la tatmadaw
réponse désolante à la victoire de la
ligue nationale pour la démocratie de
madame o o thank you qui aux élections
de novembre 2020
depuis la situation qui était explosive
est devenue dramatique caractérisée par
l'état d'urgence
la loi martiale les morts en grand
nombre lors des manifestations les
arrestations les appels à la grève et le
procès de madame hong sang-soo qui alors
vous nous donnerez si vous le pouvez
madame et messieurs les ministres des
nouvelles du président de la république
win min et de la conseillère pour l'état
aung san suu kyi et en bientôt cinq mois
nous notons que les forces de sécurité
ont déjà tué plus de 800 personnes et
ont placé en détention
des milliers d'autres dont nombre de
disparitions forcées augmentant les
risques de tortures et d'exécutions
sommaires
il semble qu'au moins 175 mille
personnes
dû fuir leurs foyers particulièrement au
sein des minorités ethniques les médias
sont fermées ou contrôler ainsi que
l'accès à internet les conditions
humanitaires et l'insécurité alimentaire
se détériore à une vitesse préoccupante
les nations unies estiment que la moitié
de la population de la birmanie
soit environ 25 millions de personnes
pourrait d'ores et déjà vivre sous le
seuil de pauvreté national d'ici le
début 2000 22 la france vous le savez a
immédiatement condamné ce coup d'état
militaire et une série de sanctions de
plus en plus sévères ont été prises à
travers le monde à l'encontre des
dirigeants de la junte et des
entreprises qu'ils contrôlent
entreprises qui sont les principales
sources de revenus de l'armée ainsi
l'union européenne vient de prendre en
ce mois de juin
une troisième série de questions vous
nous direz madame et messieurs les
ministres
si ces sanctions vous semble efficace et
si comme nous le souhaitons elle cible
bien les militaires et épargnent autant
que faire se peut le peuple birman qui a
déjà tant souffert que cherche la junte
qui annonçait ne vouloir rien changer à
la politique internationales
gouvernementales et économiques avec le
nouveau conseil de l'état quel levier
utilisé face à ces militaires qui
refusent l'évolution démocratique de
leur pays et qu'ils ignorent et trop
souvent maltraitent leurs populations
l'assemblée générale des nations unies a
condamné le 18 juin dernier le coup
d'état militaire en birmanie et a appelé
à empêcher l'afflux d'armes dans le pays
la chine notamment s'est abstenu vous
nous direz comment vous analysé cette
position de la chine
l'asian les états unis l'union
européenne
peuvent-ils contribuer à résoudre la
crise que traverse la birmanie vous nous
direz ce que vous attendez de la part de
nos gouvernements respectifs
notre collègue vice président de la
commission pascal allizard a pris
l'initiative de déposer au sénat une
proposition de résolution sur la
birmanie invitant le gouvernement
français a procédé à une reconnaissance
du gouvernement d'unité nationale de
birmanie et a apporté son soutien dans
les actions pour le rétablissement de la
paix et de la démocratie
cette proposition de résolution a été
très largement cosigné par des sénateurs
issus des différents groupes représentés
au sénat et notamment madame joëlle
garriaud-maylam président du groupe
d'amitié france birmanie nous sommes
chers amis chers ministres nous sommes à
vos côtés nous sommes à vos côtés pour
tenter de tout faire afin de rétablir la
démocratie
si vous le voulez bien mesdames et
messieurs les ministres je vous propose
de prendre la parole pendant une
vingtaine de minutes avant d'inviter mes
collègues à vous poser quelques
questions monsieur le président vous
pourrez bien sûr prendre la parole à
tout moment au sein de notre débat je
précise que nous avons souhaité que
cette audition soit retransmise de telle
sorte que le plus grand nombre de nos
concitoyens puissent entendre votre
message
madame messieurs les ministres je vous
laisse la parole dans l'ordre que vous
souhaitez
peut-être madame la ministre si vous
voulez commencer par l'académie alors
annulé remis oui mais ce smartphone chez
nous merci beaucoup à ma zhaoxu minister
of a better deals dit oui samedi
merci beaucoup de nous donner du temps
ce matin je vais proposer à mon collègue
moussa au de faire une introduction puis
nous continuerons à vous oui bonjour je
mon nom est mort je suis vice ministre
des affaires étrangères je voudrais
commencer par vous remercier monsieur le
président de la commission des de la
défense il remerciait le sénat vous
remercier pour cette opportunité et au
nom du peuple
de la birmanie vous redire notre
gratitude pour votre action dans le
cadre de l'union européenne telle
résolution également pour ces sanctions
ciblées qui donc touche aux deux
entreprises qui sont détenus par la
junte également pour avoir proposé le
gel des avoirs et nous sommes aussi
infiniment reconnaissants pour le g7
l'action du g7 donc pour le soutien aux
leaders politiques démocratiquement élu
ainsi qu'à la société civil birman il
s'agit d'un gouvernement
démocratiquement élu qui respect qui
respecte les droits de l'homme nous
n'avons que 20 minutes en tout mon cher
collègue
donc si vous pouvez résumé car il nous
faudra également répondre aux questions
sur la politique chinoise merci mon
chèque collègues entendu nous apprécions
également beaucoup le leadership pris
par la france
donc par rapport à la question de total
et des liens par avec l'industrie
gazière et pétrolière birman comme vous
le savez monsieur le président il s'agit
de la souveraineté de notre pays et de
la démocratie
la transition démocratique qui avait été
amorcée malheureusement nous sommes en
train de revenir en arrière et en cela
nous ne respectons pas la volonté du
peuple birman cette transition
démocratique qui s'est donc amorcé en
2015 et maintenant se voient imposer un
coup d'arrêt est donc la junte militaire
prend maintenant possible
le des civils innocents et de très
jeunes personnes des enfants ont perdu
la vie et ont été pris pour cible
récemment il y a également eu le
massacre du village de keane ma le 16
juin le gouvernement d'unité nationale a
bien sûr condamné ces exactions mené par
ces groupes terroristes et des témoins
oculaires ont attesté du fait que des
villages avaient été ses esprits par les
flammes et que le feu avait été mis par
cette junte militaire nous avons
également beaucoup de personnes qui ont
été arrêtées qui ont été interpellés qui
ont été mis en prison
les soldats se sont saisis de plusieurs
opposants politiques et sont allés les
arrêtés chez eux
monsieur le président nous aimerions
insisté sur le fait que le problème ne
peut pas être résolu par notre
gouvernement d'unité nationale et par le
peuple birman seul et au nom du peuple
birman j'aimerais lancer un appel au
gouvernement français il faut des
mesures supplémentaires et encourager
des sanctions supplémentaires pour
cesser ces atrocités
j'aimerais donc lancé un appel au sénat
français et à la france
pour qu'elles agissent avec d'autres
pays européens
il faut user des instruments
diplomatiques pour demander à cette
junte militaire de rendre des comptes
sur ces exactions
il s'agit de crimes contre l'humanité et
des sanctions beaucoup plus sévères
doivent venir frapper notamment
l'industrie pétrolière et gazière qui
est entre les mains de la junte
militaire en tant que gouvernement
démocratique élu
nous allons continuer notre action mais
nous avons besoin de votre aide
la légitimité du gouvernement d'unité
nationale doit être reconnue encore plus
clairement par vous la france et par les
autres états de l'union européenne
nous demandons aux états membres de
l'union européenne pas seulement de
répondre à la situation extrêmement
grave mais aussi de noces ou de nous
soutenir pour réaffirmer notre
légitimité
il est extrêmement important et et est
extrêmement important donc de souligner
que cette junte militaire n'a pas de
légitimité
on ne peut plus attendre nous bien sûr
apprécions à sa juste valeur votre
soutien pour notre lutte de notre lutte
désormais très longue mais qui se
poursuit merci beaucoup
docteur ça ça c'est à vous bonjour en
français dans le texte
merci monsieur le président chers membre
respecté de la commission des affaires
étrangères également de la défense et
des forces armées du sénat parlement de
france je ne peux vous dire suffisamment
ma gratitude pour nous donner cette pour
cette occasion que vous nous donnez et
que vous me donnez de représenter
mon peuple et le pays donc dû me and
mare devant les parlementaires français
je suis extrêmement ému de voir et
d'entendre le soutien de votre peuple du
parlement et du gouvernement de france
pour la libération et la liberté du
peuple de me and mare pour le libérer
des mains de la junte militaire est pour
nous aider à construire une union
démocratique fédérale inclusive du
myanmar pour tout le peuple de miyama
quelle que soit leur race leur religion
leur sexe leur culture leur origine et
leur ethnicité le peuple courageux de
birmanie ainsi que le gouvernement
d'unité nationale apprécie énormément
non seulement ce que le peuple le
parlement et le gouvernement de la
république française on est notamment
pour leur solidarité dans ces heures
sombres de l'histoire de notre pays et
je voudrais à nouveau réitéré ma
gratitude sincère pour le leadership que
vous avez pris au sein de l'union
européenne des nations unies et du g7
merci d'avoir reconnu le crp h et le
gouvernement d'unité nationale comme
étant les représentants légitimes des de
la voix du peuple de du myanmar et donc
votre soutien et la reconnaissance est
absolument crucial pour cesser les
crimes contre l'humanité qui ont
actuellement cours et pour cesser ce
règne de la terreur exercée par les
généraux militaires contre le peuple
innocent et je dois dire que là une
catastrophe militaires désormais se
profile car d'autres pays est en train
de devenir un état défaillant l'économie
est en train de s'effondrer le système
de soins le système d de ligue 2 le
système éducatif et tous les services de
base sont de plus en plus défaillant
l'insécurité alimentaire est en train de
s'accroître la violence et les tueries
continuent jour et nuit et les 54
millions
deux habitants du myanmar sont face à
des crimes contre l'humanité à la mort à
la destruction
et donc depuis le coup le coup d'état du
1er février les gens la junte militaire
a assassiné plus de 915 personnes dont
72 enfants
il ya eu beaucoup d'arrestations
complètement illégal et de détention de
plus de 6200 birman innocent et cela
inclut nos leaders élus notre
conseillère d'état madame en dessous çi
notre président yvonne min et des
douzaines de journalistes extrêmement
courageux et plus de 2000 civils
innocents sont poursuivies et sont
contraints de fuir le 16 juin à la junte
militaire a commis un autre crime contre
l'humanité en en détruisant par les
flammes un village entier
le village de clean m'a plus de 250
foyers des personnes âgées ont été
brûlées vives
car il était dans leurs maisons aux
prisonniers et ce n'est pas la première
fois que cette junte militaire s'est
rendu coupable de crimes de guerre de
crimes contre l'humanité et de nettoyage
ethnique déjà contre l'héroïne janosz
nos frères et soeurs contre le peuple de
karen de l'état de cash in de l'état de
kayah detian de mundra keane et de chine
qui représente plus de 40% de la
population du myanmar et donc si l'on en
croit le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
des nations unies 1,2 million de civils
on compte actuellement été déplacées du
fait de ces violences et du règne de la
terreur de cette junte militaire le
programme des nations unies pour le
développement prédit que plus de la
moitié de la population du myanmar soit
27 millions de personnes pourraient
vivre sous le seuil de pauvreté d'ici
moins d'un an
le programme alimentaire mondiale prédit
que plus de 6,4 millions de birmans
seront
bientôt face à un risque de famine d'ici
fin octobre
nous ne sommes face à ces violences plus
de 1,2 millions de birmans se sont
forcés de quitter leur foyer et 6,4
millions donc deux birmans qui risquent
la famine
nous ne pouvons pas accepter cela nous
ne pouvons pas accepter que 27 millions
de nos concitoyens vivent sous le seuil
de pauvreté
c'est cette junte militaire est
extrêmement brutal elles attaquent les
maisons des civils leurs leur propriété
les villages les villes avec des armes
extrêmement lourdes et occupe des
églises des écoles des centres
communautaires des hôpitaux pour les
utiliser comme comme baraquements et
comme entrepôt
il remplace les manuels scolaires et les
stylos par le règne de la terreur de la
peur des armes et des balles il remplace
les bibles et les livres de quantic par
l'intimidation l'oppression les tirs de
mortiers et les bombes
il sème partout la destruction et la
mort et il n'est pas acceptable que ed
des pasteurs des moines des leaders de
nos communautés soient forcés de fuir
pour sauver leur il n'est pas normal que
nos hôpitaux nos écoles nos collèges nos
universités nos banques et toute
l'économie soit réduite à néant par les
militaires il le règne de leur terreur
il n'est pas normal que nos professeurs
nos médecins nos infirmières non non
sage-femme nos ingénieurs nos
fonctionnaires soient forcés de fuir et
que le mouvement pacifique de
désobéissance civile e
monsieur ça ça nous n'avons que 20
minutes en tout et pour tout pouvez-vous
abrégé chers collègues
j'avais presque fini vous pouvez vous
résumer chers collègues entend dis-je
presque fini nous avons reçu depuis le
22 février plus de 400000 email
avec plus de 151 mille et un email
contenant des les preuves de crimes
contre l'humanité et un total de 310
mille vidéos et de photos documents
temps et attestant des atrocités dont la
junte militaire s'est rendu coupable au
miam à 4,427 affaire on était désormais
ouverte par des avocats des droits des
droits de l'homme documentant ainsi des
crimes contre l'humanité et plus de
28000 victimes et nous avons des leaders
démocratiquement élu depuis novembre
dernier et le peuple birman nous a
reconnu notre espoir est désormais que
vous nous aidiez c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de me anne marque il y à
un gouvernement d'unité nationale qui
reçoit le soutien de tout notre peuple
nous avons besoin que cette
reconnaissance soit attestée par le
gouvernement de la france et par les
leaders des pays libres du monde entier
c'est la première fois dans notre
histoire que nous eh bien eux que nous
avons une élite et donc de entre donc
non seulement un gouvernement d'unité
nationale mais également une union de
tout notre peuple c'est la première
opportunité que nous avons et il faut
absolument que nous saisissions de cette
opportunité avec votre aide
pour pouvoir et bien bâtir une union
fédérale inclusive pour toutes
tous les citoyens du myanmar nous avons
besoin de votre aide
je voudrais à nouveau lancé un appel à
vous le sénat et au gouvernement de
france pour décider de sanctions
beaucoup plus strictes
en conclusion nous avons trois demandes
c'est ces trois demandes qui doivent
pouvoir soutenir le mouvement de donc
avec votre soutien et votre
reconnaissance l'idée est que les
défenseurs de la liberté de la
démocratie puisse mettre fin à cette
dictature militaire et à ce génocide
militaire qui devient un cancer pour
notre nation et notre peuple de
remplacer par des forces armées éthique
et inclusive qui appartiennent à tous au
peuple entier et de du myanmar et qui
soit menée par un gouvernement civil
ensemble nous voulons commencer à bâtir
un nouveau me amar avec une union
fédérale démocratique inclusive de tous
les peuples quelle que soit donc de tous
les citoyens de me anne marque quelle
que soit leur race leur religion leur
sexe leur culture leur ethnicité et où
les droits humains soient respectés
protégés et promus yamar deviendra ainsi
un pays où les le pouvoir et les
ressources seront partagés sur la base
de l'égalité de l'autodétermination et
où tous les trois branches du parlement
du judiciaire et l'exécutif
fonctionnement fonctionneront en toute
indépendance
nous voulons devenir un pays où les
droits et les lois soient respectées par
eux
la nouvelle constitution fédérale du
peuple du myanmar et ceci est une
bataille une révolution que nous devons
vaincre
il n'y a aucune autre option
c'est un point de non retour et nous
vaincrons dans notre lutte pour libérer
le myanmar de cette junte militaire
brutale
nous voulons émerger avec un nouveau
myanmar une nouvelle birmanie inclusive
engagés dans la démocratie fédérale les
droits de les droits humains et devenir
un partenaire responsable de la
communauté mondiale
c'est une lutte entre la lumière et
l'obscurité entre la justice et
l'injustice entre le bien et le mal la
paix la violence la stabilité
d'instabilité la liberté et la tyrannie
l'injustice et la ju la justice et
l'injustice la vie et la mort la
démocratie fédérale contre la dictature
militaire
cette junte militaire doit être stoppée
nous vous remercions au nom des 54
millions de citoyens merci beaucoup je
vais demander maintenant à mon collègue
président du comité permanent de d'être
très bref je vais l'être je vais m'en
tenir à deux minutes mon nom et hong kee
nyunt je suis parlementaire et président
du comité permanent de l'assemblée de
l'union et j'aimerais exprimer mes
remerciements au sénat français et aux
présidents de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la commission de
défense et des forces armées du sénat
nous savons monsieur le président que
vous êtes pleinement informé de la
situation en birmanie mais j'aimerais
quand même rappeler quelques points clés
pour appuyer notre demande de
reconnaissance pour donc notre
gouvernement nous dit nationale de la
part de votre parlement et du sénat
le crp h comité des représentants du
parlement de l'union et le gouvernement
d'unité nationale
puisque j'ai très peu de temps je vais
conclure mais je serai bien sûr ravi de
répondre à vos questions merci beaucoup
kummer match c'est à wattignies merci
beaucoup et bien de ma part puisque mes
collègues ont déjà parlé de la situation
en birmanie et que notre président
président du comité permanent de
l'assemblée de l'union s'est exprimé je
voudrais juste rajouter quelques points
concernant la pandémie de qu'ovide 19
nous sommes maintenant en plein
troisième vague et les noms les les
chiffres du nombre de malades augmente
et il ya également l'impact par rapport
à nos pays limitrophes à la thaïlande la
chine et nous voulons vous demander
votre aide car la junte militaire est
complètement inopérante
face à cette pandémie et au nom en mon
nom propre et au nom de la conseillère
d'état omson succi nous n'avons pas la
possibilité de contrôler la situation
sanitaire et pour cette raison nous
avons formé un comité pour suivre cette
situation sanitaire au sein du
gouvernement d'unité nationale et nous
aimerions pouvoir nos coordonnées avec
nos partenaires internationaux pour un
effort pour pouvoir contenir endiguer
cette pandémie
il y a également de grands besoins dans
le de d'éducation pour nos enfants nos
enfants et nos jeunes ont été privés
d'éducation depuis plus d'un an et demi
maintenant c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement d'union nationale ont déjà
commencé des programmes de
d'enseignement à distance à la fois pour
les écoles les lycées mais également
l'enseignement supérieur mais nous avons
besoin de soutien financier notamment
pour pouvoir permettre à nos jeunes
d'être éduqués et nous pensons également
à toutes les personnes déplacées
il y as parmi eux des gens de ma famille
comme le docteur sa salle a dit nous
avons aussi une famine qui se prépare un
tout
rencontre donc des difficultés extrêmes
la situation politique au myanmar est
très très difficile à résoudre
bien sûr alors bien sûr nous avons
annoncé une politique vis-à-vis de
l'asian une politique vis-à-vis de la
chine et nous aimerions et bien vous
entendre sur ces points et vous demandez
encore une fois de nous aider à sauver
notre pays à vous monsieur le président
en vous remerciant merci merci monsieur
le président merci messieurs les
ministres et merci de
la force et de l'intensité des
témoignages bouleversants que vous nous
avez apporté je reprécise que cette
audition fait l'objet de retransmission
et donc elle est accessible à des
centaines de milliers de nos
téléspectateurs qui suivent avec
beaucoup d'attention les auditions de
notre commission du sénat et je pense
que c'est un premier geste que nous
pouvons faire vers vous de telle sorte
que ces atrocités puissent être mieux
connues de la part du peuple français
par ailleurs je puis vous assurer mais
mes collègues vont le faire à ma suite
que il y attend ici au sénat qu au
parlement mais aussi dans l'opinion
française toute entière un soutien fort
et des initiatives nombreuses qui sont
prises
afin déjà encore une fois de mieux
comprendre la situation qui que la junte
militaire impose à la population du
myanmar
alors bien évidemment aux demandes que
vous nous faites notamment les demandes
humanitaire elle se heurte à
l'impossibilité d'intervenir et d'entrer
sur le territoire car que ce soit pour
le coc vide ou que ce soit pour l'aide
alimentaire
nous souhaiterions mieux comprendre s'il
y a des canaux qui permettent de faire
transiter de l'aide
par ailleurs en ce qui concerne la
reconnaissance du gouvernement
légitime et
qui malheureusement se trouve en exil
c'est dans la constitution française
évidemment le pouvoir du gouvernement de
le faire mais c'est notre action à nous
les parlementaires et c'est le but de la
résolution qui va être présenté au
parlement
c'est notre volonté à nous d'insister et
de demander fermement au gouvernement de
prendre de prendre cette décision car
vous avez évidemment besoin d'une
reconnaissance internationale pour que
l'on puisse faire pression
par ailleurs vous avez évoqué aussi la
situation de total dont on sait que il
exploite des gisements gaziers très
importants et notamment un gazoduc qui
conduit vers la thaïlande
là aussi certes un début de mesures a
été pris avec la suspension du versement
d'un certain nombre de dividendes aux
actionnaires de la moit à magas
transportation company company limited
mais nous avons bien conscience que ce
n'est pas encore suffisant et nous
allons voir avec le président du sénat
quelles initiatives nous pouvons prendre
pour faire en sorte que la sanction
financière qui doivent frapper cette
junte puis c'est encore plus efficace
personnellement je me réjouis de ces
contacts et je puis vous assurer que
nous allons par l'intermédiaire de des
sénateurs qui suis-je plus
particulièrement la situation dans votre
pays poursuivre ce dialogue mais je vais
sans plus attendre
donner la parole à
mes collègues monsieur jean marc
todeschini ancien ministre merci
monsieur le président bonjour à tous
vous nous avez d'abord merci pour le
donne tableau vous a dressé et de votre
de la situation d'autres pays mais cela
ne nous avait pas échappé je pense que
nous sommes nombreux à connaître la
situation vécue en birmanie moi
j'aimerais revenir sur la situation de
vos populations notamment au niveau des
différentes ethnies beaucoup de détenus
ont pris des armes et sont la répression
est violente
est ce que vous pourriez nous faire un
tableau sur la situation de cette
répression et des groupes d'autodéfense
qui sont formés enfin ne faut pas être
plus trop long vous avez lancé un appel
au secours c'est bien puisque c'est
l'occasion pour vous de vous exprimer
comme la tille président conte bon
cela est retransmis à la télé sera
retransmis mais est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser vous puisque effectivement
le président l'a dit il ya une
impossibilité totale de rentrer dans
votre pays survolés nous préciser les
capacités d'action que votre
gouvernement et le parlement birman en
exil ont pour pouvoir agir
merci merci jean marc si vous le voulez
bien je vais prendre les interventions
des trois autres collègues de telle
sorte que vous pourrez répondre
collectivement à la suite donc je
maintenant la parole et à madame la
sénatrice joëlle garriaud-maylam qui
préside le groupe d'amitié france
birmanie ici au sénat oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le président effectivement je
préside ce groupe d'amitié depuis mon
entrée au sénat il y a dix sept ans et
je travaillais déjà bien avant sur la
birmanie puisqu'en fait je suis aussi
une amie de la famille dans le sens où
tu chies donc évidemment très impliquée
sur ces questions est très consciente
des difficultés que vous subissez en
birmanie où je me suis rendu à plusieurs
reprises bien évidemment alors notre
action c'est vrai qu'elle est difficile
le président l'a rappelé nous sommes un
petit peu bloquée parce que notre
gouvernement à cette tradition de ne pas
reconnaître de gouvernement en exil mais
uniquement l'état et là nous sommes dans
une situation véritablement de non droit
où nous avons le devoir d'aider la
population birmane et de soutenir la
démocratie alors je vais moi même
proposé une résolution il y as aux
quatre ou cinq mois déjà bon ce qui
avait été refusé maintenant je suis ravi
qu'un de mes collègues aient réussi à
faire accepter cette résolution
ce qui prouve justement combien le
parlement est de plus en plus conscients
des difficultés et des atrocités que
subit le peuple birman le jeu c'est
aussi bien sûr qu'il ya une résolution
en cours à l'assemblée nationale
également et j'avais d'ailleurs initié
une tribune avec mon collègue et
homologue président du groupe d'amitié à
l'assemblée nationale
et par de nombreux parlementaires pour
demander à la fois la reconnaissance du
gouvernement d'union nationale c'est
indispensable mais aussi et surtout que
total s'impliquent davantage on soutient
parce qu'effectivement nous savons que
nous ne pouvons pas aider directement
c'est très difficile de faire entrer
l'aide humanitaire en birmanie dans la
mesure où nous ne voulons pas non plus
légitime et le gouvernement en place et
il faut vraiment trouver des moyens de
mieux travailler alors j'avoue que je
compte beaucoup sur notre ambassadeur de
france en birmanie christ heures les
chars vie qui est un de vos grands
soutiens comme ses prédécesseurs l'avait
été il faut qu'on trouve des solutions
pour vous aider je pense que la solution
passe par total bon et j'ai fait des
appels auprès de total parce que nous ne
pouvons plus continuer à soutenir cette
armée cette junte militaire mais nous
avons besoin aussi de vos propositions
pour voir comment mieux vous aider dans
ce domaine merci merci joël maintenant
la parole est aux sénateurs pascal
allizard qui est donc l'auteur de
l'auteur de la résolution qui va être
présentée au sénat
oui monsieur le président merci
simplement pour vous remercier d'avoir
accepté d'organiser cette audition en
visioconférence elle me semblait
extrêmement importante dire à nos
interlocuteurs birman que je crois que
les choses
bougez bougez fortement effectivement en
france actuellement
ma collègue joëlle garriaud-maylam l'a
justement rappelé il ya quelques
instants
c'est à l'assemblée nationale c'est au
sénat je crois aussi pouvoir dire qu'au
sein du gouvernement les esprits sont
mobilisés même s'il peut y avoir des
différences d'approché sur les actions à
mener il n'empêche que la mobilisation
existé et c'est une bonne chose et comme
vous le savez il y à aussi dans la
société civile française et pas
uniquement dans la société médicale
française que vous connaissez bien
beaucoup de gens qui vous soutiennent et
qui défendent votre cause donc
effectivement l'étape suivante
en ce qui concerne le sénat va être le
débat de cette résolution
et c'est vrai que si j'ai eu l'honneur
de pouvoir l'initié je crois que j'ai
surtout le bonheur d'avoir près de 150
collègues qu'ils ont cosigné et des
collègues de tous les groupes politiques
donc aujourd'hui cette résolution ce
n'est pas la mienne c'est une résolution
collective et nous continuerons à la
porter ensemble pour faire prospérer
votre cause vous dirais-je en arrête là
que nous sommes à votre disposition pour
continuer à apporter ce combat pour la
liberté qui est le vôtre et malgré les
obstacles et je ne vais pas leur
détailler là aussi je elle l'a fait
parfaitement et christian cambon avant
malgré les obstacles et en ne voulant
pas effectivement trop reconnaître ce
qui se passe
le gouvernement en place qui n'est pas
légitime actuellement faire en sorte que
votre cause puisse progresser mais aussi
surtout au delà des idées que ces
massacres dont vous nous avez parlé
puisse cesser le plus rapidement
possible voilà monsieur le président ce
que je voulais dire merci pascal
enfin philippe folliot sénateurs
mais merci monsieur le président montré
très rapidement tout d'abord merci
messieurs pour la présentation que vous
nous avez fait et puis pour le courage
qui est le vôtre de mener ce combat nous
le savons dans des conditions qui ne
sont pas faciles loin s'en faut
ma question porte sur les haines les
interférences étrangères et qu'il peut y
avoir dans ce conflit par rapport aux
voisins et au grand voisin que vous avez
je pense notamment à la chine à l'inde
et et dans ceux dans ce cadre là il ya
t'il des interférences négatives ou
positives de la part de vos voisins est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire un petit
peu plus en la matière merci merci
philippe je pense effectivement que la
question de la relation avec la chine et
son attitude dans cette affaire est un
point très important sur lequel nous
souhaiterions vraiment avoir vos
éclaircissements
puisque nous avons aussi nous mêmes par
ailleurs des contacts avec les autorités
chinoises et il faut que l'on puisse
porter le bon message qui puisse vous
aider
je vous laisse la parole même messieurs
les présidents et les ministres
merci merci infiniment monsieur le
président mozac os que vous voulez
répondre en premier lieu cher collègue
puis le docteur ça ça et je pourrais
également prendre à prendre la parole
mozart à vous oui merci beaucoup pour
ces questions et bien je vais commencer
par répondre sur la chine
j'aimerais juste dire que la chine s'est
abstenue
face aux résolutions de l'assemblée
générale la proposition de résolution l
assemblée générale des nations unies
nous pensons qu'il est extrêmement
important de garder un oeil sur ce que
fait la chine
c'est très important
tout d'abord nous voulons insister sur
le fait que l'ambassadeur
donc eux il faut que les
les leaders du gouvernement actuellement
en place cesse d'être considérés comme
des interlocuteurs
le conseil d'administration de l'état ne
doit plus être reconnu comme
interlocuteur nous comprenons
l'inquiétude de la chine par rapport aux
affaires et aux intérêts chinois en
birmanie
nous comprenons qu'ils veulent exercer
une pression sur notre pays
mais le le gouvernement démocratiquement
élu peut garantir à la chine comme aux
autres la stabilité de notre pays et
c'est dans l'intérêt de la chine
également nous ne voulons pas à la
destruction des intérêts chinois qui
sont sur notre sol il faut que la chine
entendent cela mais nous pouvons assurer
la stabilité
je crois que la chine doit regarder le
long terme tiré les enseignements du
passé
les autorités chinoises ont soutenu le
coup d'état militaire
il repense à en 1988 vous savez
l'histoire se répète en 1988 1 la
dictature militaire aussi déferlé sur le
myanmar
il faut tirer les enseignements du passé
et
s'ils ne serait ce que pour la défense
de leurs intérêts depuis plus de deux
mois
un envoyé spécial a été nommé cinq
points ont été donc je parle ici de la
séan et le problème c'est que le
leadership exercé par la cn est
actuellement et est bien en dessous
et donc ce consensus sur cinq points de
l'asian doit être bien raviver et le
secrétaire général de l'aser anne est
venu en birmanie a rencontré les leaders
nous savons que cette visite a été
exploité par la junte militaire à des
fins de propagande
nous ça vous signifier à la cian qu'il
fallait nous prendre comme interlocuteur
et cesser de d'avoir pour interlocuteur
là le gouvernement militaire
et si la présidence actuelle est
inopérante et bien il faudrait peut-être
que l'indonésie ils reprennent à cette
présidence pour pouvoir cesser l'état
actuel docteur ça ça oui monsieur le
président merci infiniment pour ces
questions et merci aux membres éminents
de votre sénat bien la chine l'inde ont
le pouvoir de cesser les exactions de
cette gente militaire
et toute cette violence qui frappe notre
pays et notre population
un seul coup de fil de pékin ou de délit
pourrait changer les choses
le chaos a omis amar ne sert pas les
intérêts au contraire il est mauvais
pour la chine et pour l'inde et par
rapport à la cm par rapport à la chine
par rapport à nos voisins
il faut qu'ils prennent conscience que
ce chaos
le trafic de drogue les exactions la
violence la destruction se passe à leur
porte
et donc nous comptons sur vous pour
rappeler à la chine que et aux autres
que la démocratie au myanmar et la seule
le seul moyen de pacifier la région
la démocratie au myanmar et le sa seule
voie vers la stabilité la stabilité
économique la stabilité économique non
seulement en birmanie mais également
dans toute la région c'est un message
extrêmement important qu'il faut que
vous nous aidiez à faire entendre par
pékin et par tous nos voisins
ça fait deux mois comme l'on dit mes
collègues qu'il ya eu un consensus sur
cinq points à la séan mais ce cela ne
doit pas être à jakarta où à pékin mais
il faut que cela est bien devienne
réalité en birmanie il faut parler avec
la chine mais en fait vous savez ils ont
parlé avec la chine ils ont à nouveau on
est ressorti à nouveau un consensus sur
cinq points mais qui n'a fait que se
servir d'eux d'outil de propagande donc
qui a été instrumentalisé par le
gouvernement non démocratiquement élu
donc il faut parler
fort est clairement à cette junte
militaire la junte militaire n'a aucun
respect pour la communauté
internationale elle se contrefiche de ce
consensus de 5 points de la séan cette
junte militaire n'a aucun respect pour
les nations unies
nous sommes face à des criminels à des
organisations terroristes
le peuple birman et efface à à ce régime
voyou il faut donc et bien ensemble
entraîné la défaite car si nous ne
faisons pas il sera extrêmement
difficile de rapporter l'a22 de ramener
la stabilité la prospérité dans notre
pays
merci beaucoup docteur ça ça est-ce que
vous souhaitez mon cher collègue honky
nyunt voulait dire quelque chose oui
très rapidement en tant que président du
crp h je n'ai qu'une demande très simple
vis-à-vis de votre sénat continuer et a
appelé à la cessation immédiate des
violences
les viols les assassinats sont perpétrés
et ce sont des femmes et des enfants
notamment qui sont ciblés continuer à
appeler à la libération immédiate des
détenus politiques
il faut que le parlement français et le
sénat français reconnaissent le crp h
comme étant le parlement
démocratiquement élu de du miam
et enfin nous voudrions que vous
appeliez votre gouvernement à
reconnaître notre gouvernement d'unité
nationale et à permettre d'avancer vers
la reconnaissance internationale de ce
gouvernement d'unité nationale et ans
enfin nous encourager la communauté de
la séan à appuyer le myanmar le crp h et
notre gouvernement d'unité nationale
j'espère et je formule le voeu que nous
continuons notre collaboration de
parlement à parlement merci infiniment
merci beaucoup
chers collègues merci monsieur le
président je voudrais juste répondre par
rapport à l'aide humanitaire et sur la
santé et l'éducation
le gouvernement d'unité nationale et le
ministère de l'éducation et de la santé
ont essayé d'agir car nous savons nous
nous savions qu'il y aurait une
troisième vague extrêmement dévastatrice
et que nous allions manquer de
médicaments et que l'éducation serait
mis en péril c'est pourquoi nous avons
essayé nous avons essayé de d'en appeler
à la communauté internationale mais vous
savez la situation est extrêmement
difficile et nous nous sentons
complètement désemparé et là je crois
qu'il y a deux moyens dont pour vous
pouvez vous pouvez saisir
vous pouvez utiliser l'aéroport
international de yangon également en
transfrontalier donc vous avez
l'aéroport de d'indonésie nous ne
voulons pas d'eux le peuple birman ne
veulent pas qu'il y ait eu connaissance
de cette junte militaire bien sûr donc
c'est pourquoi je pense que la voie
transfrontalière et
est importante à utiliser bien que tous
nos pays limitrophes nous avons essayé
de parler avec la chine avec l'inde avec
le laos avec le bangladesh ça a été
extrêmement difficile et c'est pourquoi
j'aimerais vous demander et demandé aux
nations unies également à l'om est ce
également à l'union européenne
également à la france s'il vous plaît
aidez-nous qu avec un processus
coordonné des deux humanitaires
sanitaires et bien sûr de vaccin car
c'est une grande préoccupation pour nous
et ip vis-à-vis des états limitrophes
nous avons un impact de la copie 19
je suis sûr que vous allez pouvoir nous
aider notamment par la voix
transfrontalière si des pays tiers
peuvent utiliser ces voir et l'idée est
de nous aider pas bien sûr de
reconnaître de quelques manières cette
junte militaire comme et quand un
interlocuteur légitime ce qu'ils ne sont
pas le gouvernement d'unité nationale
vous savez avec le ministère de la santé
nous sommes unifiée avec les
organisations ethniques et nous avons
essayé vraiment de nous unifier avec
toutes les forces vives de notre pays
pour permettre la vaccination des
enfants
ça fait un an et demi que l'acolyte de
19 fait rage sans aucune possibilité de
vaccination donc et vous avez peut-être
entendu
aung san suu kyi qui a fait passer un
message
hier elle a appelé à l'unité et l
se préoccuper énormément de l'aco vide
donc notre action avec notamment
l'organisation de santé ethnique le à
chaud doit être appuyée nous avons
besoin de votre aide
si vous pouvez organiser et coordonner
donc il faut il faut de la coordination
et de l'intégration pour aider sauver le
myanmar
merci infiniment merci bien messieurs
les ministres
merci d'avoir répandu avec avec tant
d'émotions est aussi temps de gravité au
questionnement de mes collègues je
voudrais pour terminer cette audition
d'abord vous remercier bien sûr d'y
avoir participé
vous assurez bien évidemment que le
sénat de la république française ne
souhaite dialoguer et reconnaître que le
parlement en exil et que nous n'avons
aucunement l'intention d'ouvrir le
dialogue
de quelle que nature que ce soit avec
des représentants de la junte
qu'il soit l'exécutif ou dans quelques
organismes que ce soit donc vous restez
et vous êtes nos seuls interlocuteurs et
bien évidemment nous nous engageons par
l'intermédiaire de mes collègues de la
présidente du groupe d'amitié à
poursuivre ces échanges uniquement avec
votre parlement et votre gouvernement en
exil c'est quelque chose qui doit être
bien clair
par ailleurs je vous redis ce qu'a dit
le sénateur allizard à savoir que cette
résolution que nous allons voter
j'imagine peut-être même à l'unanimité
en tous les cas une immense majorité a
pour but de demander au gouvernement
français de tout faire pour aller vers
la reconnaissance de ce gouvernement
d'exil temps les actes commis par la
junte dépasse l'entendement par leur
cruauté par leur violence et par leur
mépris de toutes les règles
gouvernemental qui devrait était
applicable à un pays comme le vôtre
par ailleurs aussi je souhaite vous dire
que suite à cette suite à cette audition
dont je souligne la portée médiatique
qu'elle peut avoir en france puisque
encore une fois nos auditions sont très
largement suivie par nos concitoyens
je vais personnellement saisir au nom de
la commission le ministre des affaires
étrangères pour lui demander un
véritable plan d'action pour utiliser
les voies que vous venez d'évoquer
notamment par l'indonésie et par les
canaux transfrontalier afin de pouvoir
faire parvenir une aide humanitaire qui
ne passe pas par les mains de la junte
car ce serait bien évidemment une forme
de reconnaissance que de leur adresser à
eux des secours est d'abord je ne suis
même pas sûr que ces secours
parviendrait aux intéressés donc il est
hors de question de travailler avec eux
d'une manière ou d'une autre et donc
n'hésitez pas à nous donner les éléments
concrets pratique et sûr qui permettent
de faire parvenir cette aide sur le plan
de la santé sur le plan de
l'alimentation
vous savez que la france sur ce plan a
pas mal de moyens nous l'avons fait
récemment encore dans le conflit du haut
karabagh nous avons des moyens
humanitaires qui peuvent être évidemment
mis à disposition à la seule condition
comme vous l'avez évoqué que cela ne
vienne pas servir les intérêts de la
junte et que ça aille directement aux
populations qui souffrent et qui sont
concernés voilà quelques indications en
vous remerciant encore une fois d'avoir
accepté cette
cette audition vous dire que bien
évidemment nous nous réservons aussi la
possibilité de demander à notre
représentant permanent de la france au
conseil de sécurité qui peut bien
évidemment s'entretenir avec ses
collègues notamment le collègue chinois
de la situation nous souhaiterions
effectivement que la chine puisse
clarifier sa position et ne pas servir
de caution à la junte dans l' affaire
criminelle qui nous occupe avec eux
enfin notre action se dirigera aussi
vers la société total 1 qui pour une
bonne part peut apporter des éléments de
pression très fort puisque on sait le
profit que la junte retire de la vente
des gisements gaziers notamment par
l'intermédiaire du gazoduc qui nous kir
qui vous relie à la thaïlande et donc
nous allons interpeller directement la
société total pour qu'elles amplifient
les sanctions qui frappent qui
frapperont la junte
vous savez on dit en français que
généralement ce sont les sanctions qui
tape le portefeuille qui sont les plus
efficaces et donc il faut bien
évidemment rechercher des sanctions
pratique qui dépasse les déclarations de
solidarité et nous souhaitons agir pour
terminer nous avons aussi et je vous
invite à le faire je pense qu'ils sont
déjà mobilisés mais nous avons au
parlement européen des représentants qui
peuvent porter votre message et qu'ils
peuvent faire en sorte que l'europe
toute entière puisse
répercuter votre votre appel
et comme vous l'avez dit très justement
docteur sarah l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
c'est il faut que l'europe se mobilise
que ce soit notre continent tout entier
qui se mobilisent à travers ces
gouvernements
aucun des gouvernements européens n'a la
moindre
la moindre faiblesse vis-à-vis de la
junte mais ce sera mieux si les
institutions européennes qui
représentent 500 millions d'habitants
puis c'est évidemment s'exprimer et vous
aider voilà nous nous vous adressons un
salut amical et fraternel si vous me
permettez ce mot nous vous demandons je
sais dans quelles conditions vous vivez
je vous recommandant de faire bien
attention à votre propre sécurité car
les méthodes de ces gens malheureusement
laisse penser que
ils sont peut-être en mesure de vouloir
vous faire taire et donc nous vous
recommandons la plus grande vigilance
pour vos personnes et pour ceux qui vous
entourent et je vous promets donc que
par l'intermédiaire de des sénateurs que
j'ai mandaté pour le faire je le contact
avec vous demeurera et n'hésitez-pas par
les moyens habituels et je pense je
l'espère efficace de nous donner des
informations de nous donner des conseils
pratiques pour vous aider de telle sorte
que cette audition ne reste pas un
moment d'émotion mais nous permettent
d'agir pour aider vous même bien sûr
votre combat et les populations dont
vous avez la responsabilité
en espérant qu'un sursaut internationale
permettra le plus vite possible de faire
cesser cette effroyable dictature
sanguinaire et qui n'a de mépris pour
aucun des principaux auxquels vous et
nous nous croyons nous vous souhaitons
une bonne continuation faites attention
à vous et restons en contact nous sommes
évidemment à votre entière disposition
et nous vous adressons un amical salut
bon courage dans votre combat il est
aussi le nôtre
merci à vous
[Musique]